herr hofmann stellt sich bei diesem fall
natürlich jetzt die frage nach bild
informationen wurde ein versteckter
keller bei hannover gefunden wir haben
spürhunde wir haben ein großes
polizeibeamten aufgebot die dort einen
kleinen garten war ein umgraben warum
was wird dort gesucht also kennt man das
nicht an anderer stelle dass man erst
anfängt fingerabdrücke zu nehmen warum
wird da so viel gegraben jetzt auf
einmal ja tatsächlich gibt es ja im fall
maddie mccann gut indizien außerdem hat
die staatsanwaltschaft einen sogenannten
beweis gestützten verdacht sie habe aber
bis heute noch nicht gesagt was das ist
aber ganz so beweis gestützt scheint das
alles nicht zu sein denn sie fanden ja
immer auch über aktenzeichen xy wurde
zweimal jetzt nach zeugen gesucht das
heißt es scheinen ganz ganz deutlich
noch hinweise zu fehlen und insbesondere
gibt es keine leiche keine leichenteile
keine tatwaffe und mord anzuklagen und
zu verurteilen ohne tatwaffe ohne leiche
das wird schon sehr schwierig weswegen
der fall ja sogar in portugal und auch
in england noch als vermisstenfall
geführt wird weil die justiz in spanien
beziehungsweise england sagt ohne leiche
kein mord und auch keiner keine
entsprechende anklage oder keine
entsprechende kein entsprechendes
verfahren das heißt in deutschland
scheint man sich sehr sicher zu sein
dass maddie mccann tot ist und dass er
schuldig ist aber so ganz scheinen die
beweise trotzdem noch nicht auszureichen
deswegen wird jetzt händeringend
natürlich gesucht um diese beweisnot
auch in gewisser weise zu sichern nun
wurde da dieses grundstück umgegraben
spürhunde
das habe ich heute morgen schon in der
sendung gesagt spürhunde deuten nicht
unbedingt darauf hin dass eine leiche
gesucht wird könnte sein ersatz zu
suchen es gibt spürhunde für alles
mögliche unter anderem auch bargeld
sprengstoff brandmittel das ist alles in
dem fall unwahrscheinlich aber
datenträger es gibt spürhunde die
datenträger aufspüren können wozu handys
und usb sticks und ähnliche externe
speichermedien zählen und es wurden ja
schon mal auf einem grundstück von
christian b datenträger gefunden mit
auch unter anderem kinderpornografischem
material
dh dass danach gesucht wird ist gar
nicht ausgeschlossen das heißt der hund
deutet nicht unbedingt auf leiche hin
und jetzt zudem
mutmaßlichen kellerraum muss man sagen
denn ich wurde zwar große felsbrocken da
sozusagen raus gehievt aber es gibt ein
paar intellektuelle probleme die ich
damit doch habe und die man nicht ganz
ignorieren kann welche die erste frage
ist wenn es ein kellerraum kellerraum
ist muss jan eingang geben warum geht
die polizei nicht durch den eingang weil
den eingang zu finden ist er um einiges
einfacher als mit einem bagger die
komplette decke einzureißen und
sozusagen von oben rein zu gehen das
heißt wenn das ein keller ist er auch
schon länger existiert warum geht man
nicht einfach rein und durchsucht das
ganze vorsichtig um gründlich stadt mit
einem bagger durch die decke rein zu
kommen das ist sozusagen punkt eins aber
wenn wir bei dem punkt sind was ist denn
ihre antwort darauf weil diese frage zu
stellen die stellen wir uns alle was
würden sie als experte dazu sagen warum
die polizei so vorgeht dass es
möglicherweise keinen kellerraum ist
weil bislang habe ich zwar große
felsbrocken gesehen und ich kann mir
durchaus denken es gibt ja alle
möglichen arten dass man vielleicht was
verbuddelt was einmauert
es gibt informationen dass das ein
keller ist der seit längerer zeit
besteht aber man muss dann schon die
frage stellen warum lieben nicht durch
den eingang gekommen sind sondern durch
die decke wenn es wirklich kann ja auch
sein das ist eine ganz andere
größenordnung steht also dass wir oder
der eingang längst verbarrikadiert ist
und es sozusagen ein stillgelegter
keller ist und nur noch der innenraum
mehr oder weniger da ist es das ist
alles denkbar war trotzdem muss man da
sozusagen ein bisschen bisschen
vorsichtig sein
die eigentliche vermutung die er
implizit im raum steht ist ja dass das
wie im fall fritzl ist das ein
folterkeller das ja die frage die im
raum steht und da muss man sagen es ist
doch unwahrscheinlich denn wie soll er
die lebende maddie oder auch die leiche
wie soll er sie überhaupt von portugal
nach hannover geschafft haben und ohne
vorurteile gegen kleingärtner zu schüren
aber ich glaube dass auch
kleingartenanlagen nicht unbedingt die
orte sind wo man wunderbar unbemerkt von
den nachbarn machen kann was man will
wenn er jemanden keller baut oder kinder
missbraucht ist das nicht etwas was
gerade im kleingarten noch mehr
auffallen würde als ein anderer
hersteller zum kleingartenverein ich
auch so eine gewisse anonymität das
jedoch nur science macht und sich gar
nicht schert was der was der nachbar
nebenan so treibt das weiß ich nicht
genau weil ich selber kein habe aber ich
würde schon behaupten dass da er dass
das vier-augen-prinzip und dass er auch
ein bisschen geschaut wird was die
nachbarn machen
vielleicht nicht im detail vielleicht
ist es egal ob der nachbarn gurken oder
tomaten züchtet aber wenn er jemanden
der raum eingerichtet wo kinder
gefördert werden da glaube ich nicht
dass das prinzip gilt leben und leben
lassen sondern da hätte schon
möglicherweise jemand was gemeldet das
heißt erstmal wie gesagt dieses
grundstück steht irgendwie im
zusammenhang mit christian beetz hat die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt die bullen
da steine aus es sind hunde im einsatz
irgend einem konkreten hinweis scheint
es schon zu geben ob das jetzt wirklich
ein kellerraum ist und die zweite frage
ist ja ob dann auch in diesem keller
raum tatsächlich das passiert ist was er
implizit jetzt alle vermuten oder oder
was ja der grund ist warum das so
möglicherweise schlimmste ist erinnert
natürlich an die an den fall fritzl und
so weiter aber da muss man doch sagen
ich halte es nicht in dem fall halte ich
gar nichts mehr für unmöglich aber ich
halte es für unwahrscheinlich dass das
hier der fall sein kann weil man doch
die frage stellen muss wie er das
mädchen von portugal unbemerkt unter den
augen der weltöffentlichkeit von
portugal nach hannover transportiert hat
aber was fehlt denn jetzt noch konkret
um diesen fall zu lösen welche indizien
gibt es also die wesentlichen indizien
sind vor allen dingen dass er bzw seinen
smartphone da war durch die funkzellen
ortung kann man nicht immer metergenau
aber manchmal doch zumindest auf 100
meter genau eingrenzen wo sich jemand
aufgehalten hat aber ganz streng
genommen beweist ja so eine ortung immer
nur dass das handy da war nicht dass sie
da waren
jetzt sagt natürlich jeder normale
bürger mensch wenn sein handy da ist
wird er wohl auch da gewesen seien ja
aber ganz so klas eben juristisch nicht
denn streng genommen können sie immer
nur beweisen dass ein bestimmtes gerät
an einem bestimmten ort war
sie müssen auch beweisen dass er zu dem
zeitpunkt das handy in der hand hatte
und deswegen ist dieser anruf der in
dieser nacht getan wurde deswegen ist
das so extrem wichtig denn die person
kann ja auf jeden fall bezeugen dass er
dran war und das wäre dann auch der
beweis ist nicht nur das handy sondern
eher im ort war er war da was ihnen im
wesentlichen verdächtig macht und das
ist eigentlich schwache ist dass er ins
profil passt natürlich wir sehen wir
haben die ganzen vorstrafen gesehen ist
wurde ja auch in aller breite öffentlich
diskutiert von kindesmissbrauch
exhibitionismus möglichen vergewaltigung
er war da er passt irgendwie ins profil
und er hat einen tag später das auto
umgemeldet sich danach war manchmal
seltsam verhalten einen tag später auto
umgemeldet es gab diesen anruf portugal
verlassen
das alles ist eine plausible theorie
wenn mir das jemand aufgelistet sage ich
ja guter verdacht aber jetzt muss man
das eben nur noch beweisen
die staatsanwaltschaft hat aber mehr als
nur diese in die 2
denn man muss auch sagen die deutsche
staatsanwaltschaft gilt international
als gründlich und vorsichtig und die
staaten kam mir nicht vorstellen dass
die staatsanwaltschaft in dem
berühmtesten vermisstenfall der welt vor
die kameras tritt und sagt wir sind uns
sicher dass maddie tot ist und sind nun
zu 90 prozent sicher dass er sie
ermordet hat das wirken sie nicht sagen
wenn sie hoffe ich dass sie das nicht
sagen würden wenn sie nicht mehr hätten
als nur ein paar indizien die
staatsanwaltschaft selber spricht von
einem beweis gestützten verdacht und
staatsanwalt wolters war auch im
australischen fernsehen sehr klar und
hat dort noch klarere worte gefunden als
in deutschland und hat gesagt wir haben
starke beweise beziehungsweise indizien
dass maddie tot ist und dass er der
täter ist das heißt sie haben auf jeden
fall mehr als die bislang bekannt
gegeben haben ja aber sie würden nicht
buddeln wenn es nicht noch offene fragen
gäbe und wie gesagt ohne tapfer vor der
leiche ist es sehr schwer mord
anzuklagen dazu verurteilen